quantum mechanics is the part of physics
that even scientists call weird
that's because it challenges things that
we thought were rock solid
for example the notion of reality to
help explain
i've got a quantum physicist preparing
his elevator pitch
in what is thankfully a very very tall
building
that tall one
[Music]
i don't know anything about quantum
physics so you have your work cut out
for you
awesome are you ready yes let's go let's
go
what is quantum physics well quantum
physics is the description
of objects at the very small scale the
scale of atoms
electrons photons we want to talk about
reality right okay
so what is reality uh what we experience
yes right so you think the moon is real
yes
have you been there no no so what do you
think is real uh because it's observable
right i think what you're trying to say
is that everybody observes it exactly
the same way
yes right and that's what doesn't work
with small quantum systems
if you observe a quantum object you can
change it
it's like how electrons behave
differently depending on whether they're
observed or not
okay so if i tell you for example i have
two electrons
that want to point in opposite
directions like my fingers right
yeah if that's all you know for example
i hide them behind my back
and i ask you which way is my left
finger pointing
i need to see one of them tonight you
need to see one of them to know but the
thing is
you can try this experiment many times
you will always find them in opposite
direction no matter how far apart they
are
damper if i have hands that are you know
light year long this would work exactly
the same way
but if you look at them from different
angles
like from different angles from the lift
from below from left from right
you can prove that before you looked at
them
my fingers were not pointing anywhere
why
what my finger was actually not pointing
anywhere it did not have a reality of
its own
yeah yeah that
and this has been done in actual
experiments being verified
what that means this is hard to accept
but is that one of the three
following things is wrong one reality
that things are real meaning they have a
state of their own before they are
observed
two locality which means an action here
cannot influence something very far away
and three that we have free choice like
you don't have the choice
to which hand you actually look at
what
one of those three things cannot be
correct or maybe two of them or maybe
three of them
at least one of them you have to give up
to
explain and justify the way we observe
the behavior of entangled quantum
particles
i have questions good and i like having
questions
good thank you for teaching me about
things i need to learn more about
five minutes thanks for the ride so i
know i definitely didn't understand
everything but here's what i think
i did understand so we're talking about
quantum physics or quantum mechanics
which in this case is the study of very
very small particles
and how they behave in relation to each
other
so you can have quantum entangled
particles
which behave in a way relative to each
other so if we observe
one its body basically is going to
behave in a particular way
and depending on how we observe them
they're going to behave in different
ways
but in order for what we are able to
observe
to be true one of three things cannot be
true
which is either how we view reality
locality or free will all three of those
things
cannot exist whilst what we observe
also exists so it's basically the work
of figuring out
what we've got gotten wrong and i'm
going to need
another really really big elevator ride
to understand
all the rest of this
hey thanks for watching andrea has a
bunch of really cool youtube videos
where he explores quantum computing
mechanics and all the maths behind it so
if you want to see those click the link
in the description
and if you want to see more videos like
this then hit the subscribe button
see ya